Stack Pringles flavors make new ones how
much do you think Pringles paid these
people hardly anything.
Hey you guys want
to stack different Pringles flavors to
create new flavor combos hero I'll go
first.
Pizza BBQ and jalapeno. The spicy
barbecue pizza stck.
Get him. Grandpa! What's going on?! Pringles.
were trapped in a Pringles commercial
they must have taken us in our sleep
How can we get out?!
we can't summer they warned me this
would happen and I didn't listen
Stack pringles, make endless new flavors.
Make endless new flavors...
Cheddar and BBQ wavy, sour cream and onion
equals a three layer dip stack
Man, I can't believe we're back!
we're gonna be back I
mean that's right we're gonna be back!
Man, I just wanna open my Christmas presents
well I'm waiting on you to finish those
snake costumes I'm almost done you know
what they're good enough I'm done all
all right let's go
all right we're landing come on. Man I
can't believe we're almost done. Rick I
can practically taste the eggnog hey you
know what. I feel like we're forgetting
something. Oh yeah, thanks for reminding
me Morty...
next time stay in the car
Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie Happy Super Bowl
week so Rick and Morty season four just
dropped a Super Bowl trailer there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs so we'll
break it down I know there's a lot of
questions about when they're going to  drop
the back half of the season four
episodes the other five of the ten total
that are supposed to air during season
four so if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Rick and Morty videos this new Super
Bowl trailer is just one in a long line
of Rick and Morty funny commercials that
they do is part of integrations with
other big brands I'll talk about some of
my favorite Rick and Morty fake
commercials in a second but normally you
think ads would be something you don't
want to spend time watching but when
they're done really well as is usually
the case with the Rick and Morty themed
commercials it's a lot of fun there's
six really big Easter eggs and
references that I spotted in this one so
starting with number six Rick and summer
are watching a commercial for Pringles
which is a reference to Rick and Morty
watching commercials during
interdimensional cable episodes like
real fake doors but in those cases those
were real commercials for real products
and services like a plumbus is
actually something that Rick and Morty
could go out and buy in a store enduring
interdimensional cable episodes the
commercials themselves and TV shows are
also parodies of real-life TV shows and
commercials like at the end of Morty's
mind blowers they wake up to the end of
an interdimensional cable episode like
oh you made us miss it summer but on the TV
is playing a parody of house hunters and
it's a couple hunters with guns
literally trying to hunt houses that are
living running away from them
number five Rick breaks the fourth wall
realizing that he's trapped in a
real-life commercial on a TV show I did
a video a little while ago about all the
big fourth wall break scenes between
season 1 and season 3
there are a ton rick breaks the fourth
wall in almost every single episode of
the series sometimes multiple times per
episode he's known since the beginning
of season 1 that he was a character
inside a TV show even Jerry the dumbest
one of them all knows that he's inside a
TV show so I'll link that video fourth
wall break
in the description during these
commercials there's also a lot of fourth
wall breaks with Rick referring to not
getting paid or getting paid a lot of
money like when summer says how much do
you think Pringles paid for this and he
says not nearly enough implying that
he's not getting paid a lot of money the
showrunners dan harmon justin roiland
aren't getting paid a lot of money to do
this integration number four Rick
realizing he and summer are trapped in a
fake reality is a callback to the M
night Shyamalan 's which was season 1
episode 4 they were a group of zai Giri
ins led by David Cross trying to trap
Rick in a simulation in order to get the
secret formula for a concentrated dark
matter to supercharge their space fleet
that episode turned into an inception
parody with them taking the concept to
the nth degree trapping Rick inside a
simulation within a simulation like the
characters during the plot of the
inception movie moving through deeper
layers in someone's mind at trying to
get something so you could theorize
about who would want to trap Rick inside
a Pringles dominated version of reality
and what they're trying to get from him
like they're implying the Pringles
corporation is run by someone very evil
in the vein of evil Morty maybe they're
just trying to capture Rick and forcibly
brainwash him into becoming a Pringles
convert all hail our new overlords in
this new Pringles reality that they're
trying to create in real life Rick also
refers to his captors as they
quote-unquote and says someone else
warned him that this would happen and
they were taken in their sleep number
three being trapped inside an alternate
version of reality is also a callback to
Total Recall during season two when the
parasites attempted to alter their minds
creating a bunch of fake memories rick
morty the family having to discover what
about their reality was real and what
was fake
that was also the first appearance of
mr. poopy butthole who they've used many
times since then to sort of mess with
your head and make you wonder which
version of reality you're in I know
there are a lot of theories out there
that mr. poopy b*tthole is actually just
an alternate reality version of Morty
it's actually pretty decent theory and
would explain some of the
inconsistencies in previous episodes
number 2 Morty is revealed as one of
many
pringles Morty robots which attempt to
Zerg Rick and summer they're called back
to the mechanical morning and summer
that Rick created during Rick and Morty
season 3 episode 2 Rick dancing the
stone to distract Beth into thinking
that nothing was different allowing Rick
Morty and summer to dodge having to deal
with the
force and live in that alternate Mad Max
post-apocalyptic society for a long
period of time there was also a robot
version of Rick and Morty during season
1 episode 10 inside the Citadel of
Rick's but they're not the Terminator
style robots designed to look like human
replacements they're just straight-up
robot looking versions of the characters
then number one a Pringles Morty robot
is seen teaching their mantra that they
keep repeating to a bunch of other
Pringles Morty robots in a classroom
which is a callback to season 3 episode
7 in the Morty's school where they were
all being educated to become better
companions to their Rick's there were
also a lot of sinister overtones and
references during those scenes too like
on the blackboard here behind the Rick
teachers this Latin phrase act a non
verba which roughly translates to action
not words which they then paid off at
the end of the episode in the evil
Morty's scene where he says speeches are
for campaigning and now is the time for
action but speeches are for campaigning
now is the time for action so I don't
think they're trying to say that evil
Morty is behind this whole Pringles fake
reality evil Morty Pringles Corp but
they are implying that someone really
sinister is behind Pringles
so message received do not trust the
Pringles brand anymore if you ever did I
think up to this point my favorite Rick
and Morty commercials are probably the
Carl's jr. one in the Old Spice clips
but they also did a Batman 1966 parody
as a Snickers commercial too
Morty, wake up Morty! We're in a Carl's Jr Hardees Commercial right now.
I'd like you to meet some characters.
Thick burger El Diablo. Rick I don't want to be in a commercial. It's 4 in the morning.
I got a big test tomorrow.
I'd like you to meet All Natural Burger!
It's gonna help you relax morty.
Bacon cheeseburger!
I need to get sleep! They're getting sauce all over my bed Rick!
Morty
check out my new friends the Old Spice
invisible spray come on Rick it's 3:00
in the morning well why do you keep
selling us out? Meet Bearglove swagger
and pure sport.
it's too bad Morty their spray is
invisible it's invisible spray they go
they go on clear they smell great and provide 48
hours of odor and sweat protection can't
can't make it stop Morty you're going to
smell great tomorrow
Four thousand...
Some of those feel like they could be
deleted scenes from regular episodes and
I think those wind up being the more
enjoyable ones to watch so if you're
going to do a commercial with brick and
mortar if you're going to pay all that
money you might as well produce it as if
it were a clip from an actual episode I
also think the joke works a little bit
better when Morty is calling them on
their bull like why you keep selling
this out Rick why do you keep doing this
and Rick is just sitting there counting
his money like shut up Morty I just got
paid a dumptruck of cash to do this so
after watching all the Rick and Morty
parody commercials let me know which one
is your favorite I will be doing more
Super Bowl trailers depending on which
ones are released this week but let me
know if you have any special requests
for videos there should be a couple
pretty big Super Bowl trailers this
weekend I know a lot of you are asking
when of the rest of the episodes for
season four going to air they're
supposed to be ten total Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland revealed that there are
in fact 10 episodes total in season 4 but
for whatever reason there's some
production delays they had to break the
season in half just because they weren't
ready to release all ten of them
back-to-back week to week normally
without saying anything he would just
assume that they would take a break for
the holidays then come back at the end
of January like they did during season 1
when they first started airing the show
but it just sounds like those production
delays are a little bit bigger than we
were led to believe so right now based
on what Spencer Grammer the voice of
summer on the TV show said in a recent
interview she was doing voiceover or
additional voiceover dialogue for the
finale and that was back in October
sometimes it can take an entire year to
turn an entire episode of Rick and Morty
around but they don't have to finish
every single episode before they start
airing them I'm assuming it's going to be
sometime between the beginning of this
summer and the end of the summer so it
just depends on how quickly they're able
to get episodes out of animation if we
get any more information about that I'll
just include it in future Rick and Morty
bonus videos but I did do a separate
video with a lot of the interviews that
the cast and crew have talked about
behind the scenes for the future
episodes so I'll link that video at the
end of this everyone click here to watch
that and then everyone click here for my
new Marvel Eternals teaser breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!